people can't get enough of this comeback
I mean it's just a man surely the demand
after 50 years in stand-up sir Billy
Connolly is enjoying life as an artist
and despite a diagnosis of Parkinson's
disease comedy is ever-present the
Parkinson's is a great excuse that was
playing me up the Parkinson's people
policy okay I'm okay I'm a bit cheeky
I'm just going watch the telly for a
while his art now sells for thousands of
pounds and so Billy's career on stage is
officially over you should know when
you're finished and this unfinished will
stand up it was lovely and it was lovely
being good at it there was the first
thing I was ever good at so we won't see
you back on stage we'll wait no no it's
my big the Parkinson has made my brain
work differently and you need a good
thing for comedy and that brain made him
one of the world's greatest
observational comedians today's women
could easily keep secrets if they wanted
to but the dog seems to watch out good
thing you should let Parkinson's define
you I get upset because you send things
go wrong where your brain goes adrift
and affects your body and so you walk
differently you won't like a drunk man
sometimes and you afraid you'll be
judged on it we've recently heard that
Ozzy Osbourne is being diagnosed korzy I
thought you had two ages ago
Ozzy is one of the world's great people
and we've spoken to him I haven't spoke
to him about the Parkinson's but that's
another thing I don't do there's
camenisch mr. Parkinson's but he's still
very happy to speak out on other matters
more people should listen to comedians
and fewer people should listen to
politicians anybody who listens to Boris
needs profession
because because he's a big silly Tov and
its gooden's been listening to big silly
talks for years
this time they listen to themselves and
go on with it
and 77 surpassing all expectations
sabili is more than getting on with it
Lisa Casa Sky News